All right, hello everyone.
We have two second year students here.
Tal Lee Anderman and Omid Sheybani,
here with us today.
Hello Tal Lee and Omid, so
excited to have both of you here.
>> Thanks.
>> Thank you for joining us.
So can we start by you both
briefly introducing yourselves?
And talk a little bit
about your background.
So what were you each doing
before business school?
And what are your goals after graduation?
And then we can open up to some
questions from the audience.
>> Sure.
>> Tal Lee?
>> Okay.
>> So before the GSB,
I was working in the nonprofit space
at the Environmental Defense Fund.
I focused on sustainable agriculture,
mostly in India.
And then later on domestic
environmental issues.
I came to the GSB to work on
corporate sustainability and
I'm hoping to go into
that post-graduation.
>> And Omid?
>> Yes, I'm originally from Germany.
I graduated from undergrad for business
degree in Germany and Argentina and
started working for Google in Ireland.
Was there for two years.
Then I transferred to the US,
was another four years in the US working
on the Latin American market doing
cloud computing partnerships, distribution
partnerships across Latin America.
Which was a great time, but
I felt like I was ready for some, for
the next kind of phase of growth.
And that's when I decided to apply
to business school and came here.
And very much with the goal of pursuing
entrepreneurial endeavours and
that's kind of what I'm doing as
we're approaching the last seven,
eight months of our time
as second year MBAs.
>> Awesome, great.
Okay, let's look at a couple of questions.
So first, our first question is actually
coming from a college senior from India.
This person writes, I am applying for
the Stanford MBA deferred enrollment.
What are the variety of qualities that are
looked into an applicant applying directly
from college for
the deferred enrollment program?
So I can take this one.
So we do encourage college
seniors to apply to our program.
That is the earliest time that you
are able to apply to the MBA program.
And we are looking for
the exact same things.
We are looking for the intellectual
vitality, the demonstrated
leadership essential, as well as your
personal qualities and contributions.
We take all of that into consideration and
consider the fact that
you are a college senior.
So we are still looking for
the leadership.
But maybe instead of a full time job,
maybe we are able to see that in your
extra curricular activities that
you've been able to do on campus.
Or any work in your community or
if you've been able to do research or
any internships that you've have.
So we are still looking for those same
qualities in all of our people who
are applying for
deferred enrollment, as well.
Our next question for
our students is what did each of you
do to fill your global requirement?
You want to start, Omid?
>> Yeah, happy to.
So before school even began,
we had a new program.
It was a pilot when I started.
It was called the Global Seminar and it
was kind of two weeks before school began
and with I think,
about 25 other incoming MBA1 students.
We went to South Korea,
it was a trip led by two MBA2s, so
students that were a year ahead of us.
And that in itself was sufficient
to satisfy the goal requirement.
But I really personally believe that
the trips you do with your fellow MBA
classmates are not only some of the most
memorable experiences from our time here,
but also incredible
learning opportunities.
I feel like,
given the depth of these trips, and
the intensity at which you're getting
to know a country and its economy and
its business landscape,
I really wanted to do more.
So not only did I go on
another trip to China,
I also ended up currently organizing
a study trip to Italy coming up in March.
So that was my experience.
>> Great, awesome.
>> Similarly, I was on a global seminar
before the school year started, so
that was for me to Brazil.
And it was an incredible opportunity to
connect really deeply with my classmates,
before even coming to school.
And we had this wonderful
kind of safety net and
community as we were
adjusting to life at the GSB.
It was led by two second year students and
they were a wonderful resource as all of
the questions start pouring in,
when you get here.
It was also a wonderful
opportunity to learn about Brazil.
I had never been, and so
our subject was poverty alleviation and
environmental sustainability,
which was very relevant to me.
So we met with people across
the nonprofits, in politics, and
then in corporations.
So we got to learn a lot.
I likewise couldn't get enough,
although that did fulfill the requirement,
and so I went on a global study
trip to Mexico over Christmas.
And something that the global
study trips really highlight is
the value of the network within the GSB.
So our second year trip leaders were able
to organize meetings with the President of
Mexico, with the Foreign Minister,
with the head of Central Bank,
then a variety of really interesting
nonprofits and entrepreneurs.
Still couldn't get enough [COUGH].
>> [LAUGH]
>> Excuse me.
So I actually led, the Global Seminar
this summer, to Argentina and Peru, and
was able to create that experience for
incoming MBA1s.
>> And this experience of doing more than
one global experience is quite common for
our students, so great.
Okay, the next question we have is,
what is life like for
students bringing their partners or
families with them?
If you have personal experience or
even from your classmates' experience.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So the truth is,
we both came here as not married, singles.
We do however, have a lot of classmates
that either came with their SOs which
stands for Significant Others.
Or without their SO but with the children,
we have those cases as well.
I would generally like to highlight
that the GSB community given it's
relatively small size in comparison
to other schools is a very inclusive
community where you'll very often
find other students reaching out and
trying to help and
by trying to help a bit.
I heard just yesterday I was sitting over
dinner, the Germans were coming together
last night to celebrate
our cultural heritage.
And one of my classmates was talking.
She has three children.
And she was talking about how
her husband had never actually
sat in one of the GSB classes.
And I asked why.
And she said, well,
because of babysitting, and
I said I'd love to be your babysitter so
that your husband can attend the class.
I think it's just a very inclusive
community and, truth be spoken,
I think the experience
is slightly different.
You just have a different
priority if you have a husband or
a wife at home, or children.
But I think still there are many
ways you can get a lot of
learnings out of this experience.
And yeah, it's just a slightly
different one, admittedly.
>> Well, I had a couple of small pieces.
I think a lot of the families
who do come here,
they live in graduate student housing and
they do nanny shares and
there's a common play space so in terms of
raising kids there is a lot of support.
And they tend to pool resources in a truly
business school way to kind of get through
the day and create more space and
more community.
The other thing is SOs are very
integrated into the culture.
I spend more time with some of my
classmate SOs than I do with them.
There's a lot of events
after school hours,
even during school hours where SOs are
welcome, both academic and more for fun.
So they really are as much a part of
the experience as they want to be.
>> Great,
another question about admissions here.
So how much weight is given
to one's academics and
work experience while applying for
an MBA from Stanford and
how much weight for
extra-curricular initiatives?
So for us,
we are not weighting anything or place
any stronger emphasis on any one part of
your application more than the other.
We do read your application
completely holistically.
We look at you and
treat you as a whole person.
So there's not one thing in your
application that will be weighed
more than the other.
We are really trying to
figure out all of the things
That you will be able to bring and
contribute to the class.
Okay, so the next question,
back to our students, is can the students
talk a little bit more about classes
that they took outside of the GSB, and
maybe specifically at the d school,
the design school?
>> Sure, I'll start.
>> Please, yes.
>> So
I am a joint degree student in the earth
and environmental sciences program.
So I've taken a number of classes there,
one of which was a design school
class on the food system.
I mean,
each class is going to be different.
I loved both of the classes.
I took a food economics class and a class
at the D School, and the main thing I will
say is it's a great chance to connect
with people outside the Business School.
We call it the bubble.
It is hard to get outside the bubble,
and classes is a great way to do that.
The professors are obviously excellent,
and so
it's really a matter of prioritizing
what is important for you to learn.
A lot of classmates take computer
sciences classes, language classes.
Maybe I'm able to speak more to that.
But the level's phenomenal and especially
in your 2nd year you almost have complete
freedom to take whichever
classes you want.
>> Yeah, just to echo what you said.
I'm currently taking language classes.
I took language classes this year which
was Portuguese, now I'm doing Chinese.
That's something I like.
The question's also specifically
about D school classes.
I personally have not taken
a D school class yet.
I do have it however as
a really big priority for
my next two quarters at the GSB.
I felt the offering of the GSB was
satisfying a lot of my kind of
needs in terms of what
I wanted to experience.
But I think for the next two quarters,
I really wanted to venture out.
And on that note,
the D school has very often information
sessions where they present all of
the different classes that are available.
And if it's not a class,
it's a pop-up class, which you do over the
weekend, dedicated to a specific topic.
So there are different ways to kind
of engage with the D school program.
>> Awesome.
Yes, well luckily our curriculum is
quite flexible.
That allows our students to take a lot
of classes outside of our bubble.
So the next question we have is how
did you decide to choose Stanford?
want to start Omid?
>> Yeah, how did, okay, let's maybe
just to preface a little bit, my answer.
It's, Stanford was the only
school I applied to.
And I actually applied two years in a row.
I didn't get in the first time I applied.
But I was so adamant and so
eager to get into Stanford that I did it
again and it worked out the second time.
And the reason why I ended up applying
to Stanford was during my six years at
Google, a lot of the managers I had,
I had seven different managers,
mangers or directors, and I think three or
four of them were actually GSB Alums.
I always knew about Stanford.
I had a lot of admiration for Stanford but
because of those managers and
because of the leadership that
I experienced through them,
this admiration for Stanford became
an aspiration, to become part of Stanford.
And these leaders,
these managers were people that not
only influenced me professionally in my
thinking about my career, and how I show
up at work, but also very much personally.
And that was, kind of seeing the way,
how they were impacting me and
shaping me, and hearing all these
anecdotes that they brought to work from
their time in business school,
that really got me pumped and
fired up to apply to business school so
much that I ended up applying twice.
So, [LAUGH] involuntarily but still.
>> It worked out.
>> Yeah.
It worked out.
>> So I'll talk very briefly about why
business school which is a big part
of why Stanford.
I was working as I mentioned in
a non-profit in India on agriculture and
I was just very frustrated with
the current mechanisms for
making change in those ways.
Policy as we've seen, is an intense and
often varying process and
so I wanted something that was much
more streamlined and more effective and
business school, going through
the corporate sector to influence
sustainability seemed
like the way to do that.
With that in mind, I applied actually only
to environmental joint degree programs,
and so Stanford actually had a program I'd
looked at for a PhD many years before.
And now I'm doing a joint
degree with the program.
So that was an easy fit, but honestly, one
of the most clear memories I have of when
I was like Stanford is
it was an info session.
I came to campus, I'd been working in SF.
I came to the campus for an info session,
which is part of why I love doing these.
And was really interesting to talk to the
admissions facilitator, but then after,
actually one of the students who was
leading the session, came up to me.
And was like I see you're from Israel, I'm
from Israel, do you want to grab coffee?
Can I answer your questions?
And she ended up connecting me
to people in the program and
was just a real resource and
sense of support through the process.
And she didn't know me at all.
And that, for me,
really reflected the sense of care and
commitment that people have here.
And honestly,
it's only gone up from there.
>> Great.
And a quick followup question.
As you mentioned,
doing a joint degree, how do students
typically balance doing that?
And do you have any kind
of advice on how to do so?
>> Yeah.
So I, as I said,
I'm doing the Environment and
Resources joint degree.
There's people doing law degrees,
medicine, computer science,
engineering, a whole range.
And each of those experiences
are going to be different.
In general, the program is actually
really well set up to accommodate.
There's almost no pressure or
no additional work that I have to do.
It takes longer.
In my case it takes extra,
from one extra quarter to an extra year.
And it depends on how
you balance your units.
But it really comes down to choices.
And so you make choices around how
you want to use your course time.
And do you want to take
more business classes or,
or do you want to go across the street?
And those choices will depend how
much longer I end up spending here.
But then a lot of other programs,
they just integrate it perfectly.
And while you're here, you're here, and
then the rest of the time you're there.
So it's been very smooth at least for me.
>> Awesome, great,
another quick admissions question, so
would you recommend getting
a recommendation [LAUGH] from a professor?
What if you're applying
as a college senior?
So typically,
we tell people to shy away a bit from
getting recommendations from professors.
Typically, they do not provide us with the
level of leadership potential that we're
looking for, the level of
detail that we're looking for.
The biggest kind of exception to that is
if you are working with a professor doing
research or anything like that, so
if you are working with a professor
outside of class, maybe as a TA or
teaching assistant or as a research
assistant then that may work for you.
The biggest piece of advice I'd typically
give for choosing reccomnders, is to look
at the questions that we actually ask
them, that we will ask your recommender.
And if that person, whether it's
a professor or someone else you know for
a fact can answer those questions with
a lot of detail, then that is okay for
you to use that person.
So definitely use your judgment
when you're picking recommenders.
Next question is about extracurriculars.
What types of extracurriculars
are you involved in here on campus?
>> I can take that.
It's a good question.
I do a lot, actually.
So I'm on the board of four
different associations.
One is the diversity committee, which is
dedicated to raising more awareness and
making the GSB a more diverse and
inclusive environment.
Then there's the Asian Business Student
Association, I'm on the board of that.
We actually have our identity retreat
coming up this weekend in Santa Cruz.
There's 50 of us going there,
to discuss what it means to be Asian.
For context,
we decided that Middle East, originally,
I'm from Iran,
is also geographically part of Asia.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just to explain why I ended up there.
>> Yeah.
>> Then there's the Student Alumni Board,
where we kind of develop
relationships with alumnis.
And I think the last one is
women in management which is
an organization very dear to me.
We have a very large kind of movement
here on campus which is not only
by women to support and
empower each other, but also we
have an allied group which is women in
management, the main ally group of it.
Where men come together and discuss how
we can be more supportive of women.
And these four kind of activities plus
there are two trips I'm organizing,
I mentioned, Italy one, I'm also taking
10 classmates to my home country,
to Iran over Thanksgiving, and on a very
personal trip outside of school and
Things like that, so
there's a lot going on.
There's really no limit to what
you can do extracurricular.
>> Yeah, right, want to add anything?
>> Yeah, as I was also involved with
WIM last year, and I'm the head of
the Food and Ag Club, but I think
the most important extracurricular for
me right now is
the Arbuckle Fellows Program.
It's a leadership program that
you do in your second year,
and part of the program is to teach,
actually, a squad of first year students.
Every first year student takes
leadership laboratories, and
that lab is a group of six, which is your
squad, and it's led by a second year.
You also do a series of coaching,
one-on-one with the students, and
that's been just phenomenal opportunity
to develop skills as a coach.
But also get to interact with first year
students and practice my leadership.
I'll also just say on the side,
I am a yoga instructor, and so I was
teaching last year yoga classes every week
for classmates in our residency at Schwab.
So there's just really unlimited ways
to give back and to get involved.
>> And I still have to make it to a class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They're over now.
>> Okay.
>> Missed opportunity.
>> Great, so for you specifically, Omieb,
can you talk a little bit about what life
is like here as an international student?
>> Yeah, so I actually lived in the US
four years prior to starting at the GSB.
And what it's like as
international student, I certainly
didn't have the experience of actually
having to move for the GSB to the GSB.
Because I've also been living
in the Bay Area previously.
I really appreciate kind of the number
of international students we have,
personally I wish we had even more.
I think I very much connect very
well with international students.
We very much also celebrate the fact
that we come from different countries,
we, is it this weekend?
Yeah, on Sunday, we have a big food fair.
There are 15 different countries preparing
food from their nationalities where we
kind of celebrate the diversity, the
geographic diversity we have at the GSB.
And I think that's
a phenomenon that I've seen
at schools as well as in the workplace or
in my social circles outside of school.
It's just people just tend
to bond possibly quicker and
in an easier fashion with
people of their own kind.
And I think these are tendencies,
as I said, you find everywhere.
But the good thing really that I
would like to highlight is that,
there's not too much of group formation.
So people do come together to celebrate
a certain element of their identity.
But at the same time, this element
is also celebrated by other groups.
So we have a lot of cultural
events that are highly or
frequently visited by
also American students.
So for example, the Asian Student
Business Association is very close with
the African Business Student Association.
So there's a lot of support between
the different identity groups.
>> Yeah, anything to add at all,
just with your interactions at all?
>> Yes, it doesn't really cross
my mind in a day to day way.
Not because I'm not aware
of our diversity, but
because there's a really fluid
relationships between people of
all places, American and
across all other kinds of identity.
>> Great,
a question about faculty members.
How accessible are facility members,
and do you have an example of
a meaningful interaction you've had with
a faculty member since you've been here?
You start.
>> Yeah [LAUGH] a lot, honestly.
So very accessible, I have to just very,
to say very honestly this week,
I had a 50 minute twalk,
which is talk and walk, as I call it.
>> [LAUGH] Those acronyms.
>> Yeah.
>> With Baba.
>> With Baba?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[LAUGH] Sorry.
>> It was a different professor, actually.
But we just walked and
talked for 50 minutes.
He's one of my professors.
I just dropped him a line and
said I want to to pick his brain on
some of the entrepreneurial projects
that I'm currently pursuing.
Yesterday, I signed up to host
a faculty dinner where one professor
would come to our house, and we would host
a dinner for him and seven other students.
I would say they are very accessible.
They are always willing to meet.
They are always willing to advise.
I have seen in the past,
there have also been cases of
professors helping you with funding.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So it's very, very, very close.
Not only do they know you by name very
quickly, again, because of the class size,
but they also really care,
and I made it a priority for
myself this year to meet as
many professors as possible.
And they are absolutely willing,
and it's great, I love that aspect.
>> Great, thank you.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Additional thing,
I completely agree with that.
I think they also go in a very
wide variety of ways to invest in
the community.
Over the past couple of months,
a very established politics professor
we have here, Keith Hennessey has been
doing lunch time BBLs to discuss
the progress of the election.
>> What is BBL?
>> Brown bag lunch.
[LAUGH] We use acronyms all the time here.
And so that's just his way to kind of
give back and answer people's questions,
and get involved.
Similarly, there's a really
popular class you'll hear
called managing growing enterprises,
taught by Joel Peterson.
And there's some students who don't get
into the class because it's a lottery
system, so he, this quarter, ended up
hosting a series of seminars at his house.
And so people who didn't get into his
official class were able to go to
his house and kind of hear a lot of
the learnings that he shared with us.
And that, just I think across the board,
people are really committed and invested.
>> Yeah.
>> Great, so how have, if at all,
have your career aspirations
changed at all from your time here?
[LAUGH] How do you think about that?
want to start, Tal Lee?
>> We're smiling because we
were just talking about that.
[LAUGH] So
I have actually had a pretty big shift.
I came in thinking I wanted to
sustainability specifically around farm
sourcing and sourcing product in a more
environmental and socially friendly way.
I did that this summer.
I was at Blue Apron and
their farm sourcing team, and
I realized in a lot of ways that the thing
that was interesting to me about that
space was the people I
had been working with.
I had been working in India with
a lot of small holder farmers.
And it was those connections
that had really motivated me and
less of the food part.
So I came back, and I kind of potentially
have scrapped that entire hypothesis, and
I'm looking at much more people-focused
roles and kind of leadership and
management.
>> Yeah, I came with a vague
idea around entrepreneurship.
And I was very intentionally vague about
it because I think these two years,
there's a lot of different
opportunities crashing into your life.
Quite literally, a single conversation can
change the direction of your thinking.
Be it with a classmate,
a class or a professor.
And I've been actually very open to that.
I still want to pursue entrepreneurship.
I nevertheless decided this summer
to work in venture capital because I
spent my career in technology.
But I wanted to move from the operational
side to the financial side of the table.
Realized that I don't like it,
which now makes me want to look back
into the operational side of things.
And what I'm currently working
on is one idea is within
a class called the Startup Garage.
Which is a very experimental class
based on design thinking very much and
to other ideas.
So it's still entrepreneurship,
and I think the beauty in general,
is that you're exposed to a lot of
different kind of career paths and
other people's career aspirations.
I think you always need be a little
true to yourself, and when you enter
the program, just have a rough idea
of where kind of your north star is.
Because with all these different
people who are equally ambitious and
determined, it can very easily happen
that you get a little influenced by that.
Or being inspired is great, but
maybe being influenced by other people's
decisions is certainly not the best.
So you want to have your north star, but
be open to kind of the inspiration
coming from your classmates.
And I think that's how I've been faring so
far throughout the two years.
>> And just really quickly, what are
the resources that you've been able to,
hopefully been helpful to you,
and thinking about how you pivot?
>> Yeah, so we have a crew management
center, and there are career advisors, and
I'd meet with one pretty regularly.
And I was teasing here
with a group of students,
like yeah, I see Grace every week.
And she stopped them and
she's like no, no, no.
Talia actually comes in to every week.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that's a very helpful resource.
And then they have a lot
of visioning workshops and
obviously a lot of different people
you can talk to, to help explore and
negotiate, and Walk through that process.
>> Yeah.
>> Great.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Okay.
You already touched on this a bit,
Talia, about electives and
getting the classes you want.
So what is that process like
in choosing electives and
do you typically get
the classes that you want?
>> Shall I?
Me?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay.
Do you always get the classes you want?
Most of the time, yes, but not always.
And I think an important lesson that I
learned throughout my time here is really
knowing what you want.
And then once you really know what
you want, you prioritize that.
There's a Election system basically.
You make those classes your priority and
you get them accordingly.
I would, how I'm choosing electives?
The beautiful thing of the GSB is we have
a huge range of different
types of electives.
Classes that are focused on environmental
topics, Classes that are very data driven,
Classes that are very interpersonal,
kind of touching interpersonal topics.
I just made the decision that,
I want to focus on my strengths,
not to compensate my
weaknesses here at the GSB.
So I'm not taking many
financial modeling classes,
I'm focusing more on philosophical,
interpersonal type classes.
And you know, there's a big variety,
my favorite elective so
far Has been winning writing with
Glenn Kramin, who he's a former
New York Times I think former editor
in chief if I'm not mistaken.
And he had this two week class about
how to become a better writer.
Be it giving feedback to your employees,
be it an op-ed that you write Or
other types of content called emails so
we rehearsed that.
And again, there's a big variety and
you can choose them by
just reading the reviews,
there's descriptions online but there's
also student reviews about the classes.
What I did I asked a lot
of my MBA two friends.
What did they take?
What do they recommend?
And they all responded and
gave me their lists.
And I took that as a starting point, yeah.
>> I'll just add another, my personal
favorite elected has been in her personal
dynamics, which is commonly
known as touchy-feely.
But I am taking winning writing
next quarter, so who knows.
[LAUGH]
>> Good, you'll love it, it's great.
Great.
Awesome.
A couple of other quick questions
about admissions and financial aid.
So talking a little bit about financial
aid and how that works, our financial aid
application happens after you have
already been admitted into the program.
So once that happens our process
is need based, fully need based.
What that means is,
after you are admitted you will get
information about the financial aid
process from our financial aid office.
You will submit documents,
talking to us, and
helping us understand a little bit more
about your assets and your income.
And the level of fellowships that you will
receive will be based on that information.
So whether you are a domestic student or
you're an international student,
you are eligible for fellowships.
We will also talk to you
about loan options as well.
The other question from financial
aid is talking a little
bit about the Stanford USA MBA fellowship.
This is a brand new fellowship that
we have launched this year and
with this fellowship it
is specifically targeting
students that have very
strong demonstrated ties
to the 12 states in the United States
that make up the midwest region.
So we have a ton of information
about this on the website,
we also have a recording of a previous
webinar we did about the fellowship so
if you have any further questions
you can ask about that.
The specific question here is what
are we looking for in a candidate?
So with this process, you will apply to
the fellowship within MBA application.
So we're looking for edit baseline
the exact same thing were looking for
in the general MBA application.
So the intellectual vitality,
demonstrate a leadership potential and
the personal qualities and contributions.
In addition to that, we are looking for
you to help us understand what your ties
are to the region and also the impact that
you want to have upon your return
to one of those 12 states.
If you are interested in
the fellowship you must apply
by the round two deadline this year.
And again for more information
definitely check out our website.
Another question back to our students is
what has been your favorite experience at
Stanford so far?
We'll start with that,
you want to start Talia?
[LAUGH].
>> Sure, goodness!
I guess the highlight, in essence what
I'm taking from that question, for
me I was getting a talk.
Talk is a tradition we have at
the GSB every Wednesday night.
Two students come up and
give a talk on their life.
The origin, I just found out,
it was basically someone saying,
" you know there's so
many incredible people here and
we don't really know that much about
them because everyone is so humble." And
Andy Dunn who was at JSA was like well
why then you don't talk about it?
And so it really is just a chance
to talk about who you are.
And I was fortunate to give I
think the third talk of the year
which was basically talking to
a bunch of people I didn't know yet.
And from that it was incredible
the number of emails and
kind words and people really
out to really get to know me.
And so it It made me feel very
safe in the community and
also very respected and valued.
>> Yeah, favorite experience, I gave
a talk as well and I agree with you Talia,
that is an extremely rewarding experience,
to share your story with your classmates.
For me,
my highlight however was the GSB show.
>> Mm.
>> Which is a musical that
is entirely Written and
directed and produced by GSB students.
And it's a comedy you can say and
kind of making fun of
ourselves here at the GSB and that for me
was a highlight because not only because
of the effort that went into it but also
because of this Really cool opportunity
to be on stage with your classmates and
entertain thousand two hundreds,
professors, fellow classmates, significant
others, and so on and so forth.
Yeah.
>> And it was very entertaining.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
What was your role?
Did you sing, act, dance?
[LAUGH]
>> So
the funny thing is I was
actually only acting.
But They gave us microphones.
So I had a microphone on my face
all the time and I was dancing.
And while we were dancing,
some people in the front were singing so
everybody thought I was also singing.
So everybody was kind of congratulating
me on how great of a singer I am but
they didn't know that microphone was
actually off while I was dancing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Personal things, so.
[LAUGH]
>> Awesome, great.
Okay.
So question about what is the best way to
prepare to get the most out of Stanford
for those who are able to
be admitted to the program?
Talia, You want to start?
>> Sure.
I ask myself this a lot.
Still asking myself this.
Time is quickly ticking away
on this incredible experience.
I think feedback I got that was
super helpful was to spend time
with your loved ones.
I cannot underestimate how intense of
an experience this is and how little time
you will have to spend with friends and
family outside of this world.
Not because you don't want to, but
because your day is just incredibly full.
So really,
if you can, take the summer or the year
before to spend time with people you love.
And the other thing is to prioritize.
Things will change as we've discussed, but
if you have a clear sense of what you
are here to get, it'll be that much easier
to make the decisions that flow
in almost on an hourly basis.
There are so many opportunities with every
hour of your day here and without a clear
sense of what your priorities are, it's
really easy to get swept away into things
that are really cool and really valuable,
but maybe not what you're here to get.
>> Yeah, I really want to echo that.
And I kind of mentioned
earlier as the North Star.
I feel if you come to school,
you should have a general idea.
You should have a really good idea of
who you are, what your values are, and
kind of stay true to them
throughout the experience.
As I said, I think there's a lot
of There's social pressures.
There's social influences.
A lot of things you're exposed to
that kind of shape your thinking.
They can really drag you into
all different directions I feel.
But if you know what you came here for
and what you want to get out of it,
As Tal Lee said, if you know your
priorities, in advance that really helps
make good decisions and
be happy with the decisions we make.
>> Great, okay well we
are coming up on 45 minutes, but
before we go just a couple last things
almost tied to the previous question.
Any final words of advice for
people who are still trying to figure
out whether an MBA is right for them.
Do you want to start for me please.
>> Yeah, yeah it's a tricky question.
I, there is no right answer,
I don't think.
There is no right applicant or
right student for an MBA.
An MBA is such a diverse program and
such a diverse opportunity that
people from all different walks of
life can get something out of it.
I once, someone once told me you
get an MBA if you want to lead,
if you want to be the executive
of a large organization.
And I had that in the back of
my mind when I came to the GSB.
But I think at the GSB,
I realized that it's not true.
For me personally, an MBA is
an opportunity to challenge my thinking,
to make amazing new friends,
to take classes that push me.
And really also just have some
intellectual kind of freedom to
pursue things that I at my time at
Google would have never considered.
Just one quick example, I was working
on developing an investment thesis for
Iran, and I wanted to pursue
that over the summer and
I worked on it with a professor.
But that's something I would have never
even considered while I was at Google.
But at the GSB, you're exposed to so many
great things that it makes it possible.
Point being, I think the MBA
gives you a lot of opportunities.
It really comes down to you If you
want to take advantage of those or not.
>> I think that's great.
The only thing I will add is in
terms of whether or not it's right,
or when it's right,
really just try to figure out who you are.
And I say that because that's a huge
part of the application process.
It's also a huge part of what we do here.
I would say more than half of my time
is spent on reflection and feedback,
to better understand what my strengths
are and what my values are, and
then to improve upon those.
That comes into play very strongly
in the application as well.
So as much time as you have,
given to making that decision.
I would say personally
I allocated a lot for
that time towards just figuring
out who I was and what I wanted.
And from that I think naturally
decision hopefully will flow.
And in terms of timing, I started my
application in October for round two.
I thought I should just wait a year and
then forget it.
And then I said who cares I'm just
going to give it a try and it worked out.
So not saying that's the right path but
certainly don't limit yourself just
because you don't think it's
the right from external pressures.
>> Great, well thank you so
much Tal Lee and Omid for
joining us and
all of you around the world for watching.
You can learn more about the MBA
program on our website and
by watching our videos on YouTube.